work accidents can happen at any time  but what are some things you should do  in case you are a victim of one eric  palacios from eric palacios and  associates the sponsors of this segment  tells us more  welcome to the legal minute i'm attorney  eric palacios today we're going to tell  you three things you need to do if you  suffer a work injury  number one be sure to report it to a  supervisor immediately it's best to have  confirmation and this can be done with a  text or an email number two seek medical  attention as soon as possible although  you have 90 days to see a doctor the  longer you wait the worse it is for your  claim  number three tell the doctor or the  medical staff that you were injured at  work this way the doctors will fill out  the correct forms to protect your claim  this has been the legal minute don't  forget to download my app eric palacio's  legal app  and you can always get more information  by giving eric palacios and associates a  call at 702-444-7777